Chris Sims came in when I was doing the
display I was showing this presentation
and you won the punt pass and kick
competition when I'm in New Jersey right
and you didn't get a trophy no you got
very special Phil Simms autographed
football it was hilarious I don't even
think the people that were putting on
the punt pass and kick competition
realized what first place was so then
when they gave it to me they started
they kind of like opened up a package
started laughing I was like what they
laugh at that how's it go okay great
I'll put it on my put it in my bedroom
yeah I got an autograph from your dad
yeah explain this by the way Chris Sims
from NBC sports you can see him with
Mike Florio Monday through Friday Pro
Football Talk your top 10 all-time list
yeah the quarterbacking position right
so the rationale yeah for your top 10
list was right well I mean I mean just
how good of a quarterback are you you
know that's the way I kind of an
accomplishment it's not accomplishments
to me know you know accomplishments hey
that's not even close we know Tom
Brady's number one there that's hands
down yes I got you now yeah just because
his team and he was a part of so many
great accomplishments you know again I
just don't always say he's the greatest
of all time I don't I'm not always gonna
go with accomplishments there because
what are we gonna start saying Eli
Manning is better than Brett Favre
because he want an extra Super Bowl I
mean no you know that's not to be true
or I always go back to my old saying
I mean it's phil simms better than Dan
Marino cuz he's got it absolutely not
I'm not gonna say that so you know the
accomplishments sometimes I think we
take the team we're in this era right
now of quarterback on a pedestal and
he's the reason you win and lose and you
know sometimes I just try to fight back
against that narrative and yeah I just
I'm going off of what I think the best
quarterbacks are so the most talented
quarterbacks of all time you got Aaron
Rodgers John Elway yeah then you put
Brady in there yeah I think break
Brady's talent is underrated Brady is
special I mean his arm is special you
see now he still got a hundred mile per
hour fastball he can still throw it 65
70 yards down the field you know and
then Brady's toughness and size and all
that yeah I mean I think Brady is
definitely one of the three best
quarterbacks of all time and I would say
that if the only one two or three Super
Bowls I would be saying that it says
does nothing to do to me with the Super
Bowl Peyton Manning not not athletic not
a big
no not a thought but but again sighs
more athletic I think then he gets
credit for you know an arm that's really
good and then I mean Peyton Manning you
know he kind of changed football with
what he did to so some of they like the
coaching slash quarterback that he was
on the field yeah I kind of combine that
together with that as well and I mean
Peyton Manning for Super Bowls with four
different head coaches I mean the things
he did I think Peyton's uh you know
great also you're talking about talent
but you know your mind yeah you know
that's something that's something that
goes into it no doubt about it none of
these guys really are stupid I mean you
know some are may be smarter than others
right Bradshaw Terry's my buddy he knows
I'm just joking uh but you know I'm
looking at Roger Staubach how talented
he was
yeah right and Bradshaw you know was a
javelin thrower in college everybody was
he was a great athlete yeah never gets
really mentioned when we talk about
great quarterbacks of all time well I
mean you know and again because there
was not a great team and he won four
Super Bowls and I think people kind of
wipe it away but I mean you know but he
won two NFL MVPs won two Super Bowl MVPs
and you know was a big-time player not
always easy to play in that style of
offense to run the ball run the ball
okay now it's third and down throw a
bomb to stallworth or lynn swann
you know that's not always easy
sometimes it's easier to be dink and
dunk and dink and Duncan kind of being a
rhythm throwing the ball to Joe Montana
is behind Marino I know yeah that's the
one you probably you heard from a lot of
people yes I did and Drew Brees being
tenth on your list right because you had
just set the record see biased to I
think people you know I mean we even did
a poll on PFT this week where people
said like right now they would take Drew
Brees over Tom Brady and I want to be
like if this poll was taken five weeks
ago or six weeks ago I don't think
that's the case but because New England
struggling I mean six weeks ago
you know Drew Brees was three and two is
the starter and Teddy Bridgewater was
five and OH so but you know it is a
little recency bias Drew Brees is
awesome he's amazing there's no doubt do
I think he's a little overrated in the
all-time lure of things yes you know do
I think that John Elway or Dan Marino if
they were playing with Sean Payton in
this era would they put up stupid
numbers of course they would you know
and then the other thing I look would
a breeze - and again you know if you're
the top ten of anything I'm trying to
like say this so people stop that visser
rating me sometimes you top kind of
anything you're really good all right
but you know drew brees you you're not
gonna be top five to me when you have a
stigma of you can't play in three
quarters of the stadium than the NFL you
know that that to me just says it all
almost right there
you know it's he has a stigma of not
being able to play outdoors and cold
weather that's to me where I go like Tom
Brady stats compared to Drew Brees
they're not even comparable
yeah but Peyton Manning benefited from
this shirt but he did go to Denver at
the end and showed that that was capable
to where he threw 55 touchdown passes
and played in Kansas City and other
games to a you know he didn't have the
stigma of oh gosh he's going outside the
Colts are gonna lose with Hayden Manning
he didn't have that you know - I look at
that you know of course a perfect
offense that's around him you watch the
game on Monday night I mean how many
Lamas the best receiver in football he's
matched up against guys were going at
how did he get him matched up against
the linebacker a safety whatever it may
be that way - and then you know yeah
drew you know one Super Bowl no MVPs I
think that speaks to a lot of it - a lot
of its yards and it's great and
completion percentage but yeah I just
don't think he's as talented as the guys
I got in front of the best quarterback
in football right now is oh I'm gonna
give it to Lamar Jackson right now I am
yeah Lamar's one and I'm gonna say
Patrick mahomes is - yeah but where's
Aaron Rodgers Aaron Rodgers is really
probably three to me right now three to
four somewhere in there I think three
four and five right now just where I
look at it between Rodgers Watson and
Russell Wilson very debatable there you
know I would yeah I it's I haven't
thought about my recent top five a whole
lot but that was how I would juggle I'm
pretty confident in Lamar one mahomes -
and then three four or five I'd have to
sit down and tinker with it a little bit
I would take Russell Wilson as you would
take over mine yeah I get it I'm not
gonna I get you I mean there's nobody
I'd rather have with the ball with the
game on the line here that I know people
the only they scream like are you you
take him over Brady and Aaron Rodgers
yes with the game on the line I would he
is he's almost unstoppable in those
moments I mean just like the 49ers game
in overtime when he drove them down he
threw the interception you know we're so
used to seeing him deliver
you're like he threw an interception
like it was like shocking but I I'm with
you I I really think most of the year it
was him one in two I thought the last
few weeks he hasn't played his best
football but I have no problem with that
you know and again talk about an offense
it's not easy sometimes Dan you know
that's they like to run the ball there
their schemes I look at I don't go whoa
they're reinventing the world here with
their past schemes and when he drops
back to pass he they drop back like look
into like 20 yards yeah 25 yard past 50
or he doesn't dig and um no he does not
thinking dunk we're talking to Chris
Simms Pro Football Talk live co-host and
NBC Sports NFL analysts of course a
former NFL quarterback yeah and we were
just talking about the biggest play in
Super Bowl history
yeah was Malcom Butler against y'all
right I think that won a Super Bowl yeah
I think so
you know I think I think about it it's a
really good one that's up there now I I
just don't understand Manning throwing
the pick six
and then maybe Scott Norwood wide right
I think the onside kick was this big
you're right I think that was bigger
from the standpoint of momentum and the
surprise element right yeah well that's
a good names Harrison's interception
against Kurt Warner no doubt was an
unbelievable they knew what they were
gonna do they knew right play right and
he went back in coverage right and then
to beat the clock and get into the end
zone is amazing cuz Arizona had total
kind of momentum and control at that
entire reason he didn't score a
touchdown it led to a touch tonight
it's an incredible play yeah I'm with
you I think Malcolm Butler would
probably be one eye on estanque that's
the that was the greatest Super Bowl
I've ever watched and to put that up
there too you know and to watch and this
Russell Wilson was the best player on
the field right until that final pass
yeah but I don't understand the still to
this day yeah and it's sensitive if you
bring it up to Pete and us and I
understand that but like from a an NFL
perspective yeah when that play comes in
right because I thought if you throw a
pill I wanted to run pass option that's
all run pass option sure and if you
don't have your receiver
I want him outside where he's the only
one who can get yeah I hear you it was
they I think the thing that I drove me
crazy about it is it was
they go to play for them all year long
and I want to just be like if if I when
they lined up today you could ask my
buddy Adam left go a bleacher report I
went oh they're gonna try to throw the
pics land underneath here we were
watching the game together and of course
they did it and if you think I knew it
I'm pretty sure Bill Belichick knew it
right and then you know the thing that
also drives you crazy the play before
what was it Marshawn Lynch up the middle
for seven yards down to the two or one
yard line yeah and you know I also say
this to people blame Russell Wilson
that's not a Russell Wilson that's like
that play is like you catch it and you
throw it you trust it it's not a play
where you have enough time to read it's
a bam bam play but if Malcolm Butler he
joined us after the game yeah he said
coach told me on Wednesday night when
you see this go right for the ball right
and so it builds a bam bam play you know
and yeah so they taught they taught him
he was ready for it they were ready for
it and Bill saw the chaos over there but
that was a great Super Bowl and I'm with
you I think that's probably is the
greatest play in Super Bowl history yeah
you just you got one team that gets the
fourth they're their fourth Super Bowl
Brady gets four they had lost two in a
row the Seahawks we were all gone is
that gonna be a dynasty where they were
up what 20 to 10 at some point in the
fourth quarter right something like that
I mean that was a lot of big plays and
big-time players but you're looking at
Pete Carroll then with two Super Bowls
Russell Wilson with two Super Bowl right
like you're viewed completely different
yes when you add the second one yeah you
go in a different strategy Brees had two
Super Bowls right I think on a lot of
lists
he'd probably be in the top five I get
you yeah I know yeah I think I think the
rover's had one right right he'd be a
different player no doubt it's it's a
shame that you like crazy it it's crazy
that it comes like your dad I always say
if your dad had another one he's in the
Hall of Fame in might be probably if he
doesn't get hurt for that second one
where ha stellar plays and they beat the
bills and all that yeah probably you're
right but that's that's the way it is
it's the way it's determined that's okay
but he did have had a good career did
anybody have a better who said it Steve
Young had a better game than your dad
yeah Steve at the six touchdown pass
against the Chargers right but your dad
had a near-perfect game against Denver
I think you still got the completion
percentage record for you at the game I
was there yeah six and a half I mean
that was I could still remember sitting
there I mean it was pumped to Disney
World was at halftime Mickey Mouse I
mean come on it was fill Elway and
Mickey Mouse couldn't go wrong it you
were six years old six and a half years
and a half yeah right yeah wait are we
aware at what point do you say you don't
put the half on there well we get like
two and a half when you get older you
know yeah I'm 39 and a half best game
this weekend
ooh best game this weekend that's a good
one I know there's a lot at stake with
Ellis in Philadelphia yeah is that the
best game this week I don't think it's
the best game no I mean because
Philadelphia and best game don't go
together right now but the way they play
their defense not good I mean it's
carson wentz just jamming in one more
you know six and seven yard completions
one at a time and the tight coverage so
you know I I really think the best game
of the weekend is it to me it's either
the bills Patriots or or Packers Vikings
okay
yeah one of those - I mean Rams Niners
is in that list who I guess I'm most
excited for Bills pad Patriots because I
think the bills
I'm not picking them to win but I think
one mistake by the Patriots I mean one
interception or fumble or something like
that and they're there they could be
primed to lose a game like this because
Brady even though he's not playing well
this year he has not made mistakes right
he's done great that way
Josh Allen makes mistake he will make
mistakes but you know there's a
different Josh Allen now than during the
you know early part of the year 100%
they were winning in spite of him right
now I think they're winning in part
because of no doubt I agree they they
they they took a little office plate
like when I went back and watched the
first matchup between the Pats and the
bills this week I like to go back and
just go and what happen and to your
point they had Josh on on the shotgun a
lot and they were like oh we're just
gonna let Josh throw the ball all over
the place and it was a disaster he threw
three horrible interceptions and it
really led to them losing the football
game they've kind of dialed back what
they asked of him they play a little
more of a balanced game running throwing
take a shot here and there you could see
he's got tremendous talent and he's
matured I think he's realized like okay
wait
well our defense is really good I don't
need to go out and throw 50 yard bombs
into triple coverage all the time and
you know he has superstar potential
I think everybody's seen it a little
with his arm and his athleticism in his
size but if I just saw we know the more
Jackson now it is of that draft class
right the cream of the crop and you like
Lamar coming up I did and I liked him I
did rap yeah he wanted to play
quarterback and he was a quarterback in
college who looked to throw the ball and
then when it wasn't there he ran but do
you think because he was so good at
running that you know that we or the
scouts didn't think he was good enough
as a pass like it sometimes if you're
really good at one thing then we assume
you're not really good at something III
think so along with the color of his
skin I know I'm sorry to say that but
yeah you got pegged as like oh he's a
black running quarterback that's what he
does and I just you know I think there
was more to it than that and then you
know to I think you know as you watched
him was the throwing always like oh wow
that one point on point perfect throw a
perfect throw no you know you'd have
some games read go this is amazing and
then the next game he'd go man he's like
2 4 5 on slant routes that are open
today you know so he had some mechanical
flaws he needed to work out which he has
and you've seen already he's just he's
grown as a passer this season right in
front of us okay but if we put Lamar in
a separate category and you can have all
the other quarterbacks yeah you're
talking about Josh Allen being the
potential to be a superstar yeah be my
team right now so you take him over
Mayfield Arnold yeah I would you know
it's close because they're all talented
and I like all of them I always say this
and I've said this a few times lately
because this drives me crazy see this is
where to me like bias comes in the media
everything people that follow the sport
if Sam Donald or Baker Mayfield were ten
and four right now and had just gone
into Pittsburgh and done that the world
to be gone oh are they the greatest
thing since sliced bread look at the
gold that the brown struck with the
first pick in the draft or the jet
struck but because it's Buffalo and Josh
Allen you know I don't know what it is
but it doesn't get the credit it
deserves but yeah I would go him one
well he went in there to you know I went
in marburg he went in to Dallas yes like
those were impressive rhymes with not
people around him where you're going
like oh well if you don't stop John
Brown you're in deep trouble but but you
can't be a better
runner than a passer at that position no
no and he's still a better runner than a
pass yeah it's it's yes you're right
it's closer closer he's still a backyard
football kind of guy for sure the team
that you can see slow down Lamar Jackson
is who oh well I again you get Bill
Belichick the second time you know I'm
always skeptical of that I do think it's
a really tough matchup for the Patriots
this year they have they lack big people
for the that game will be in bold it'll
be in Baltimore but I'm oh I'm never
gonna doubt New England and Bill and Tom
totally would yeah I wouldn't use I
would say the other team though is
really the an obvious one it to me in
the in the AFC its its Kansas City
you know Kansas City is a tough matchup
for a Baltimore you know there's a
reason they beat them you know the last
two years
Baltimore likes to get in your face play
bumped and bump and run man-to-man they
don't want to give you anything easy
that's like like patching mahomes like
oh my gosh they're gonna play bump run
man are in on Tyree kill this is amazing
I'm gonna get to throw 50 yard bombs all
game so that's where it's scary for them
all the Chiefs should been quietly
getting better getting better their
defenses better and their defense has
size up front to where I don't think
Baltimore can just steamroll them and
control the line of scrimmage where you
know with the run game and everything
like that handicap I don't know what to
expect out of Dallas yeah now I'm on
record is loving Dallas and they were
gonna be my Superbowl pick if I didn't
take Philadelphia yeah okay I really I
really thought Dallas was gonna be great
this year I did too okay I don't know
what to expect out of them I know dak
and his shoulder and those kind of
things but you got the Dallas Cowboys
figured out no absolutely not but I mean
like to your to what your thought is and
everything like you're not you're not
wrong Dallas is clearly as we saw again
last week you know this is the crazy
thing about Dallas it's you know the top
offense in the league top seven defense
and yet they're like the 13th best
record that doesn't make sense that
tells you something about their
management of the game of the style
they're playing is not working
something's not correlating there but as
far as the team itself there is talented
as any team in football I mean we need
to go through the positions right
I mean dak Prescott he's arguably a top
five top eight quarterback offensive
line top three in football running back
definitely top five defense alone top
five
Bakkar duo top 5 corner duo top 5 safety
is probably the only position you can go
to and go they're not top 5 in that so
no I don't have them figure it out but
are one of those teams I would just say
watch out for like if they get hot they
can play with anybody in the league if
your urban meyer and jerry jones offers
you that job yeah would you take it I
would yeah I would it's the Dallas
Cowboys and they're set up right now for
a run they they really are you know they
got some young stars the offensive line
signed up for a while but if Washington
or Cleveland calls is there a better job
than Dallas if dallas comes open i don't
think there is I think Dallas is really
special the big thing you got a deal
with the Dallas is just the Jones family
and who listen I got a lot of respects a
lot it's a lot cuz I said that I if I
was Lincoln Riley I would stay at
Oklahoma and not take the Cowboys job I
would - I don't think that's the right
fit like you know again and not to say
Lincoln Riley can't do it but I feel
like this team is ready now you don't
want to have a coach that's like oh let
me get used to the NFL and the way the
NFL is that that to me he's more made
for like what Kliff Kingsbury did in
Arizona okay we want to build something
Lincoln Riley you want to bring you
there with a young quarterback and groom
it and make everything about that that
would be more the Lincoln Riley approach
for me like Cleveland like Cleveland
could work that way yes Chris Sims Pro
Football Talk live co-hosts NBC Sports
NFL analyst great SIA you the man for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]